so if we could
talk about Giancarlo who had an
incredible performance and I mean
there's a lot of things we can say we
can probably go through his matches but
if we could just talk without that about
some of the most impressive things he
saw about him one of the things I think
you mentioned uh elsewhere in here is
about confidence so one of the things
you saw that could really benefit him as
an Athen and competitor is to build up
his confidence is there uh can you speak
to that first of all I should give you
some background John Carlo bedoni was a
um uh a strong
uh local black belt in Boston
um teaching at Bernardo Faria school
when I would film instructional videos I
would often talk to them and talk to him
about his competitions and training and
he would do local competitions he was
trying to go from gear training which
was the majority of his competitive
background into nogi and he was
struggling uh in local competitions
especially for things like leg locking
where he had no background and leg
lock-in and would often get submitted so
as we work together in instructional
videos we uh we would talk and discuss
how it would periodically come to the
gym in New York City and coming to work
out with the guys and
um he often struggled in the training
room he had no experience with things
like body like guard passing and this
used to uh mean that he was uh many of
the training sessions didn't go well for
him
um
so it was always like a very polite
well-spoken young man and uh worked hard
um
when we went to Puerto Rico and the team
ended up drifting apart
um
when we moved into Austin uh
he he said you know now that
many of your athletes have left could I
come down and train with you guys full
time and I was like yeah I'd love to I
thought it'd be a great training partner
for Gordon and Gary we didn't really
have any training Partners at that point
and
um uh sure enough he literally just
picked up everything he had and moved
down to Austin
um now anyone who just moves halfway
across the country to begin training
that already gets my respect right there
that's a big commitment and
um uh he began training we put him on a
uh a training schedule where first he
had to cover up his big weaknesses he
had limited attacks from uh bottom
position he had poor leg lock defense
and he was very very vulnerable to
um certain kinds of guard passing which
weren't part of his experience this is
all a year out from EGCC yes and we
should also maybe
uh give the the spoiler which is he wins
his division in a dominant fashion
he also does incredibly well at the
absolute anyway it was an amazing thing
um to give you an idea when he first
moved to Austin he competed in um
wno event and I don't think he scored a
single point lost a couple of matches
and
um uh and including matches to people
who were in this ADCC so
um uh he came out of that looking very
depressed and uh he lost to Kenan Duarte
he lost to um uh Mason Fowler
so Giancarlo always struck me someone
who was positionally sound he he had
like good guard retention things like
this but he had no offense he had no
leglock defense and he just wasn't able
to assert Authority on matches he was he
was a guy who's always going to be tough
to be because he was hard to pass his
guard that kind of thing but he wasn't
dangerous can I ask you a question on
that yeah because my interaction with
him uh early on when he came to Austin
I remember he interrupted me a bunch on
the match showing me stuff but I wonder
if that kindness is a detriment to the
confidence is there some connection
again Killers can be nice too absolutely
confidence comes from skill level and
um uh confidence is much more
rational thing that most people ascribe
people think of confidence is like this
esoteric ethereal element that you
either have or you don't when in fact
confidence is much more a reflection a
rational reflection on your past
experience and if you're successful with
your past experience and you're
expecting to
uh
compete in a situation which is similar
to your past experience and that past
experience has mostly been successful
you'll be confident are you pretty
confident that the sun will rise
tomorrow of course you are because it's
done so every time in the past now
there's no
as people like Hume pointed out there's
no Supreme rational reason for for
believing this but nonetheless your
confidence is high and it's the same
thing in Jiu Jitsu
um if if you're performing well and
skills are uh the reason for that your
confidence will be high in the future
regardless of what your mindset is so
it's not a question of you know this
personality does better in competition
or that personality ultimately it's
going to come down to your skills and um
and your confidence will be a reflection
of your accumulation of skills
so what was his journey like to a person
who lost to a person who dominated the
competition yeah first things first we
had to say okay you've got an obvious
weakness leg lock defense so
um every day in the gym he would be
taught okay this is where you put your
feet this is where you position your
knees your point you need this way not
this way
um uh then he would have to start
sparring situations in leg logs and have
to work his way out
um initially these were like
heartbreaking
presentations for him where I mean I've
got to give that kid full credit like he
just worked his way through it patiently
dealt with frustration initial failures
and just said I'm going to get better
can we just look on that so what's the
experience of those early training
sessions like foreign
thought that you're not going to ever be
good yeah you're wondering if I even got
what it takes like you you think about
it he's he's an established player who's
been an ibjf competition I believe he's
a brown belt world champion in the ghee
um and suddenly a group of kids
that he's never even seen before
repeatedly submitting them with leg
Longs yeah in the gym and he's like man
this this is terrible like a year from
now I'm supposed to fight 80cc against
people like
Craig Jones like some of the best league
Lockers in the world like it must have
been hard you know
um
but he just stayed in there and no one
worked harder than him he just was in
the gym three times a day studying every
day and unlike so many other people
every time he was showing something he
consciously and deliberately tried to
enact it even at the price of initial
failure do you advise that that's a good
way to go it's the only way to go
like if you if you can't wrap your head
around the idea
that trying to acquire new skills will
create a temporary time where your
Effectiveness diminishes as you're
trying to bring on new skills you're
never going to make it because you'll
always stay at whatever skill set you
are
the whole mental trick is to is to
imbue this idea of delayed gratification
that you have to accept that when I
bring on new moves
My overall effectiveness will diminish
but there's the belief that in time as
my skill performance increases it will
increase over time but it will come at
the price of initial frustration and
failure and John Carlo made that mental
uh switch early on in its time in Austin
and to his credit just stuck through
within a very short period of time it
came very hard to lay Lock And even the
best leg Lockers in the room had a hard
time with them and that's that was the
first step in confidence to say okay I'm
not getting finished quickly anymore
then he had to bring in a whole new set
of uh upper body submissions he
neglected upper body submissions when
you sell property submissions didn't
mean novel holds arm locks things like
this and um uh in particularly put very
very hard work on his strangleholds
um he had always been someone who was
positionally strong he could get to the
back but he could never finish from the
back and then suddenly in the Jeremy
started finishing from the back and then
as gym performance against the Lesser
students increased then you bump him up
against better students and then this
goes on all the way up to the best guys
in the room
and uh in time in a relatively short
period of time there was significant
increases in performance and uh success
begets success and this kept going
we started to get a hint of
his developing confidence and local
competitions I remember putting uh Saint
John Carlo compete in a local fight to
win competition against the tough
Brazilian kid John Carter just came out
dominated and finished with a leg lock
now that was that was interesting to say
okay
you're the guy that used to get finished
by leg logs and now you're beating tough
opponents with leg locks and that was an
important psychological step for
Giancarlo bedoni and um uh with each
little step as we went further and
further uh then he got to ADCC trials
and had one of the Great Performances
um I believe he submitted all of his
opponents in ADCC trials and uh put on a
fantastic display of crowd playing
shockingly
no one paid attention to it
they were just like oh yeah he won and
no Giancarlo flew into ADCC completely
under the radar they discovered oh he's
the guy that won American trials
and uh no one really paid much attention
um in his first match he took on a great
um uh Brazilian Champion uh izaki and um
uh one in dominant fashion he was about
to strangle him with just a few seconds
left on the clock and I remember John
color being furious at the end of the
match
um thinking like I was so close to
finishing he wanted a perfect finish and
uh up on point six to nothing yeah and
uh still Chase still chasing I mean he
could have just coasted at this point
but he wanted to finish every one of his
opponents and uh he got very very close
but not quite there
and um
then in his next match he had to take on
the defending gold medalist from the
previous uh uh uh ADCC amateurs and
years this was the guy who was the
favorite to win so you have a relatively
unknown John Carlo fighting the man who
defeated Craig Jones in the previous
ADCC
foreign
he's a very strong wrestler so Our
intention was to match his wrestling
with John Carter's uh uh Judo skills so
um you'll see if we could
um perhaps go back
you'll see the first uh takedown
um
on drag
and took him down with a simple dragon
pick so that was John Keller's uh first
takedown that was more wrestling
oriented and good for his confidence to
see that he could uh score a nice take
down
but um uh Matthias Denise is very very
good at standing up from bottom position
if we just go back just the stamp okay
now here we have something interesting
Matthias comes up from bottom sees the
leg and John Carlo defends the wrestling
move and then goes immediately into it
with a it's kind of a mix of society and
uh I thought it was beautiful I didn't
even notice that that's really nice look
at that
from from uh defending a single
threatening a guillotine
one of the big themes of our ADCC Camp
was that most of our opponents now
getting very strong in hand fighting
look at that but they are not strong in
foot fighting
and so we put a very heavy emphasis on
on uh foot sweeping attacks you'll
remember Gordon Ryan took down Andre
Galvan with a foot sweep and here you
have John Carlo using the same uh
technique not from the back but from the
front and the Nova hook uh
lovely
catches the foot medium look at and it's
just a beautiful beautiful takedown
that's beautiful Judo
and then uh and then later on the match
you'll use a kosaragake another
classical Judo takedown uh to get top
possession
at one point Giancarlo was in trouble
he got his back exposed
with this situation good
double leg to uh to a knee Pig
so he has to uh expose his back in order
to avoid giving up takedown points but
here's a defensive training that we work
on is is coming through
he's defensively sound shuts out the
hook prevents the score
keeps his body at the right angle to
prevent a power half Nelson
staying calm
now he's got to turn this around
it's one of the hardest things to do in
grappling
how dangerous is it to put your uh in
this position to put your hands on the
ground
um it's ordinarily it could be dangerous
because your opponent could switch to a
number whoops and there's the body log
now there's some controversy here but
you can clearly see it uh the hands were
locked so it shouldn't really be as
controversial as people are saying now
watch for the right leg because sort of
Gaga here pulls in the hips exposes the
leg boom and down
game
also probably a lesson that uh
complaining to a ref does not protect
you from a good Tick Tock yeah that's
why they say in Combat Sports defend
yourself at all times
um but now the the great advantage of of
Judo takedowns over wrestling Lake
tackles is they can fur upper body
connection after the takedown which is
very very important for ADCC that's why
we put such a heavy emphasis on them and
um now John Carlos is absolutely in a
driver's seat he just scored four points
for that takedown so he's well ahead at
this point against the established
favorite for the entire weight division
so now Matthias Denise has to start
taking some risks he's staring down the
barrel of defeat there's not that much
time left and that's what's going to set
up the the pressure now it's tactical
pressure it's not physical pressure it's
Tactical
the test has to turn away
and that's going to create back exposure
the most dangerous kind of exposure in
ADCC
oh there it is
Mount to back
and uh
Giancarlo capitalizes
materials are smart he's keeping on the
side so that less than 75 percent of his
back is on the floor to deny the uh the
mountain points but that comes at a
price and that price is back exposure so
the thing we talked about with Gordon
the the circumstance of Fate which is he
has a lot of grueling tough matches and
still chooses to do absolute so what's
and he seems to just power through all
of it what how much of it
how much of the calculation is how to
survive the cardio the grueling cardio
aspect of all of this that's uh it's a
great question and the truth of the
matter is you can't
forward to pace yourself
because if you say I'm going to hold
myself back for this match an
expectation of the others you could end
up losing your first match so he didn't
Pace himself at all any of the matches
you have to just be in good shape and
that's what they're some of the camp is
going on
no it's mostly physical you've that's
what the camp is for like he's felt more
pressure in the training room that he
felt in any of his matches
but still sort of attacking look at this
there was a beautiful transition from
back or from whatever the heck that
position was
uh a rate for uh from looking for the
back transitioning here what the heck is
this transition so Matthias is engaging
in a very good tactic which is to get
most of his back off the ground to deny
the amount points so as back exposure
starts okay he turns in threatening yeah
but you can see what's happening here is
the left foot goes under it's going to
create a beautiful triangle entry
right foot penetrates through underneath
the neck
and now he's locking a triangle a
senkagu but not just any triangle a
triangle with the the figure four locked
on the back of the opponent's head which
makes any kind of stacking defense very
very difficult it makes it very very
hard for an opponent to pull away and
creates a much tighter strangle than
average
and as a result it's a quick submission
beautifully done still chasing the
submission yes uh with a minute left up
on points against the former Champion
against the former Champion that's match
number two now that's the first day
that's Saturday so John Kohler goes to
sleep that night thinking okay I just
beat a world champion in my first match
and almost submitted him and I just
submitted the defending Champion so of
course he wakes up on Sunday morning
feeling pretty damn good now there's an
interesting twist here his opponent is a
talented young Irishman who won European
trials I believe almost entirely with
leg logs and almost all of his major
attacks in the tournament so far have
been leglocks now bear in mind that a
year ago John Carter was losing to local
blue belt competitors via leglock yeah
so in my mind I'm thinking okay how's he
going to handle this is with the leg
lock training kick in and you'll see the
result
foreign
Owen from Ireland is employing the same
tactics that we made famous uh years ago
the idea of sitting to Butterfly Garden
looking to entangle the legs he's kind
of playing that game so um so John
Carter's obviously used to this from
training the gym so he's doing a good
job of preventing entanglement a
controlling his opponent shoelaces and
moving out to an angle which limits his
opponent's entry options so hands on the
shoelaces and angles uh is a good
defense here
it's an initial defense now his opponent
wants to get underneath the center of
gravity so John Carlo wants to get
outside the uh the line of his legs at
some point your opponent is going to
entangle if he's determined to entangle
at some point it's going to happen so
John Carter decides okay let's let it
happen
and let's see where his feet go and see
how disciplined he is with his feet
and the opponent is inverted
uh here does a good job getting behind
John Carlo's knee
so now they're fully logged in so John
Cullen moves away to protect the heel
rotates out and controls the shoelace
now at this point the irishman's
starting to lose discipline with his own
foot position okay he's so focused on
his own attack that he's starting to get
a little sloppy with his own foot
position you see he's assuming oh I'm
the guy who's attacking so my oppon will
be afraid of my leg logs and is starting
to make some small technical errors that
John Carter will take advantage of so
he's threatening the sort of the
north-south passer
like uh
yeah yeah it's not putting too much
pressure on the past because we're still
pretty early in the match and
um he's not ready to score yet so here
again he turns away his heel now his
opponent's starting to get more and more
Cavalier with his foot positioning to a
point where now it's just downright
sloppy
so Giancarlo sees it identifies it locks
up a wrist to wrist Toe Hold and breaks
his foot
how how
where's the
dumb question where's the control here
how is he the control comes from his
opponent the entanglement is his
opponent's ah his opponent is holding
his own body in place with his own legs
so he's the root of his own problem here
so you got sloppy well done well done
and a little smile from drunk that was
very nice the reason for that smile you
can probably guess is because
a year ago
this would have been a disaster and now
instead it's a guaranteed ticket to the
finals in either a gold or a silver
medal and so you can see in that
compressed moment that's the look of a
man who's made who's just recognized as
how much progress he's made and what was
once a weakness in roughly 10 months was
the time it took and so uh he faces
Lucas Hulk Barbosa in the in in the
final here now these do have a history
um Hulk is beaten uh John Cullen many
times and um so for John Carlo it's a
question of okay
here I'm matched up against a guy who's
repeatedly beaten me
how am I how am I going to turn this
around now and in terms of we talked
earlier about confidence if confidence
was just a mental thing
Giancarlo never would have won this
fight when you've lost all those times
to to an athlete
um words aren't going to change anything
but you can see right from the start
when they get into the hand fight John
Carlo is much more tactically Adept with
his hand fighting he's doing a good job
of controlling his opponent's hands
preventing any kind of prolonged
pressure on the head and Hulk gets a
sense here in which he realizes he's
fighting a very different person
and this goes this goes a long time
again another Super grueling match
wrestling
that eventually leads to a back take
care back triangle
body drawing up what is
it you can see the same tactics utilized
by um golden Ryan
back control based around the body trial
many attempts to try and entrap his
opponent's arm and take away those
defensive arms the main difference here
is again you have an athlete with a very
powerful compact neck so neck
penetration is difficult and so John
Carter will switch to a a palm to Palm
strangle instead of the conventional
figure four
foreign
now there's eight minutes left so all
the time in the world
is it only just a matter of time at this
point in situations like this yeah John
Carter has a massive tactical lead and
points there's literally no way he could
lose this match at this point
um even if his opponent did get out of
here and take him down
John Carter would still be hit on points
so at this question the question now is
not whether John Carter will get the
gold medal but whether John Carter will
will get it by submission and there it
is there's the penetration of the neck
and he can't get the figure four so he
asks for Palms Apartment instead and
there's the submission
foreign
relatively unemotional man but you can
see there's there's emotion that's
that's not fake that's genuine and
that's the emotions of a man who
10 months ago couldn't have done that
and then 10 months later by Dent of his
own hard work and and dedication and uh
his ability to to actively attack his
weaknesses and turn them into strengths
and then develop an ability to uh to to
finish
that that was a truly truly remarkable
achievement